kann ich die besten spieler hallo mein
name ist finken herzlich willkommen wir
heute zu einem neuen video sieht schon
im titel eingeblendet wir spielen heute
super mario ran
das wohl am meisten erwartete apple
spiel aller zeiten an
so sieht das ganze im menü aus also okay
das ist doch gar nicht das menü das ist
bisher unter start screen hier klickt
ihr einfach mal auf bildschirm berühren
dann wird alles hier weiß ich muss jetzt
meinen land auswählen das ist schon so
eine typische wie schrift und design und
alles hier kommen aus antigua und
barbuda
okay das soll ich dir nicht mal nicht
das immer so komische sprachen habe
deutschland kommen wir her so
aufgebracht ist bei den temporekord
verknüpfe und speichern daten
wiederherstellen kann mache ich nicht
erst mal möchtest du dem lizenzvertrag
zustimmen natürlich mache ich das ich
will auch eigentlich ende jetzt muss ich
mir noch ein profil anlegen alles klar
kann ich nicht einfach mal mario spielen
mein erstes spiel was ich wirklich auf
meinen game boy advance früher hatte der
hatte nicht mal beleuchtung man musste
chur bilden um zu spielen
okay das bis hin zu krass wir mussten
nicht kurbeln aber was ich sagen wollte
mein erstes spiel war super mario
advance irgendwie so hieß das und dass
das war krass und du konntest es
reinschieben und du weißt es nicht ein
großes wenn du warst direkt im spiel der
musiker wird ein profil anlegen durch
luca und klicke jetzt auch okay und
jetzt komme ich jetzt wieder bildschirm
schwarz und lieber mario hast du lust
mit uns im schloss zu feiern es gibt
orte
ok pietsch ich bin auf jeden fall mit am
start dabei wir haben hier mario und der
freut sich und läuft jetzt schon weiter
ist eine fette party gehört irgendwas ii
es geht jetzt ab die studios pause
hahaha ich hab mir jetzt eure torte und
peach gleich dazu ok weiter browser
jetzt gibt weg und mario läuft los
willkommen bei super mario rall in
diesem spiel auf mario automatisch das
heißt ich muss quasi ein dass man münzen
auch kleine hindernisse werden ganz
automatisch übersprungen das damals gern
brücken hier muss ich auch nie gefunden
hier läuft dann einfach drüber da jetzt
auch drüber
[Musik]
hätte ich gerade springen müssen nach
einem fehler schwebst du in einer
luftblase in die richtung aus dem kamst
okay das ist ja relativ cool das heißt
ich werde jetzt abgedeckt und kann jetzt
hier weiter laufen und kann
wahrscheinlich
es gibt auch gegner kleinere gegner
befindet mario mit bocksprüngen ganz
automatisch das heißt da läuft einfach
drüber da muss ich wahrscheinlich
hochspringen gehöre dem bildschirm mit
mario springt je länger die berührung
desto höher springt er okay dass der
springer lange jetzt unter normal hier
wird ich bin auch ein bisschen hier
spielte relativ lange doppelsprung gibt
es häufig auch noch irgendwie gerade
gesehen hier war super
natürlich klasse mitgenommen die blöcke
springe bei bocksprüngen vom gegner aber
mit coolen aktionen grenzen
[Musik]
jetzt bin ich nicht zum größer und muss
jetzt die hier sorgen drüber springen
jetzt kann ich ihr gauchos dingsda
hinten wird attackiert scheiße scheiße
scheiße scheiße
es ist schwarz irgendwas liter super
mario rang kann nur einer
mit nur einer hand gespielt werden das
probieren wir aus leute handhabe ich
hinterm kopf super datendownload geht
richtig schnell ein prozent da habe ich
eine 200.000 anleitung lernen dann
braucht der so fucking lange wieder
springen an einer wand um einen seite
nach hinten zu vollführen das ist das
ist cool
nach einem langen ball rollte
automatisch ab das ist auf jeden fall
super und er ist immer noch erst bei
drei prozent megageil danke drei wochen
später
wieso braucht er so lange ich glaube ich
lass dir mal zu ende laden hier und dann
sehen wir uns gleich wieder eine
ewigkeit später so leute das ganze wird
jetzt endlich runter geladen nach
irgendwie 20 30 minuten wir befinden uns
hier mit tot auf einer fläche und er
wird uns zu und tod spricht zu unseren
einen browser hat prinzessin peach
entführt er hat auch ihr schloss der
stadt und alle 1000 geflohen bewusst
unbedingt etwas unternehmen okay dann
werden wir das ganze mal machen also das
ist jetzt wahrscheinlich das menü hier
mit noten auf welten gehen dort rein und
sehen wo es gibt mega viele welten die
prinzessin ist bestimmt ein bausatz
festung eingesperrt schnell hätte sie
okay gut dann werden wir auf die erste
welt draufklicken werden auch start
drücken und dann sind wir direkt im
ersten level leute los geht also ich
habe hier direkt zwei von den teil
bekommen hier springt mario automatisch
hoch hier muss ich einen langen sprung
machen genauer viel drauf sagt hierüber
hier könnte ich mir noch sonnen gegen
die müsste er eigentlich alleine genauso
was passiert jetzt weitergeht
hier der ganzen stadt mit ihnen die
münzen mitnehmen hier lagen oben läuft
meine zeit runter komischerweise also
irgendwie zum ganzen wohl auch zeit
tatsächlich auch immer auf diesen teilen
wenn ich darauf stehen bleiben wir das
ganze angehalten okay das ist neu es
weitergeht ich den schub nach oben hin
und nehmen hier noch ein paar münzen mit
hierüber über die kacke hier über die
kacke darüber die kacke hier hoch und
jetzt
ist wieder alles auf stillstand ich sehe
gerade oben rechts dass ich nicht alle
von den liedern in münzen mitgenommen
habe aber ich bin auch schlecht von
daher ist das vertretbar weitergeht wir
nehmen hier vorne den mit über die teile
springen darüber dass sagt 1 tag und
viel rüber und hier gegen die drauf war
ja nicht mitgenommen dummkopf hier die
letzten münzen noch mehr
das ist jetzt ich bin super level
geschafft
supercool mario freut sich das ist
unsere bilanz wie viele leute wie
getötet haben
viele münzen wir bekommen haben wir
klicken auf weiter und jetzt haben wir
quasi in welt einst ein nächstes level
freigeschaltet können hier wieder auf
start klicken und sind direkt da drin
wir können hier quasi die ganze zeit an
der wand her hoch springen hier zeigen
wir wieder runter gehen gar keine münzen
mitgenommen luca hier müssen wir glaube
ich genau einfach so hoch springen hier
wieder über die kanten rüber ihnen
getötet und jetzt hier in die röhre ich
glaube ich nehme gerade so wenig münzen
wird aber ich bin auch neu in dem
spieler das ist ja gerade mal das zweite
level also ich komme jetzt auch nicht so
übel klar ich glaube ich könnte überall
oben auch noch mal irgendwie
zurücklaufen und kann mir auch ein
bisschen zeit lassen ich mich aber noch
60 sekunden übrig aber so genial so
genau so kann ich wieder zurück laufen
aber ich hab halt irgendwie weiß nicht
ich hab auf zeit bin ich immer ein
anderer mengen
ich muss mich auch gerade wieder voll
konzentrieren alles hinzukriegen aber so
kann ich glaube ich nämlich immer wieder
zurücklaufen dann nämlich die münzen
dann kann ich auch so wieder
zurücklaufen
so so so so und das geht nicht ok hab
hier weil dadurch kommen böse pflanzen
raus dann mache ich hier wieder so einen
doppelsprung links rechts links rechts
hier natürlich verpackt war ich schlecht
bin so so hier hinten hoch oder vier
runden
und jetzt versuche ich noch mal hier die
münzen mitzunehmen habe ich natürlich
nicht geschafft ob ich jetzt geschafft
und jetzt geht mario wieder durch die
röhre ist oben angekommen und jetzt
sieht es ganz so aus als wenn das jetzt
das war wenigstens fünf münzen zum ende
bekommen hast du dir in einem durchgang
alle fünf rosa münchen geht es danach
darf um einen cent münzen einer anderen
farbe zu ergattern okay das ist cool ich
habe nur zwei puppen scheiße
relativ schlecht ab ich wollte mit einer
hand machen also hinter den kopf wir
sind im nächsten level meine damen und
herren nämlich schon im dritten level in
dieser welt ich versuche jetzt mal alle
münzen zu bekommen habe es nicht
geschafft aber direkt die erste vorhin
also ich denke wir wissen mittlerweile
ja es geht mit einer hand also das ist
so ein bisschen anstrengen die über dem
kopf zu halten weiter geht's deswegen
hier in super mario
ich warte mal eben auf den cooper da
vorne damit ich den hier mitnehmen kann
und mit ihnen da oben hochgehen kann
genau kann jetzt hier runter hier
hierüber es macht mir spaß wieder so ein
bisschen mehr
da unten das ding das kenne ich noch von
früher da konnte man dann da war so cool
software passt nicht zum korb
ich bin so schlecht es ist einfach nur
scheiße
warum ist die stadt das ist ein ganz
normaler durchgang also weiter geht's
hier lang und sechs münzen
wir werden besser am ende jetzt haben
wir das letzte level hier freigeschaltet
und alle welten absolut welt 1 bis 4
sind eher spiel bei wenn du sie gekauft
hast ist euer ernst also hier steht
jetzt nicht an weil 1 bis 4 ausprobieren
und 20 sekunden aber das ist doch reine
abzocke wir langsam den abgezogenen hier
da oben habe ich den natürlich wieder
nicht mitgekriegt die münze aber das
wissen wir mittlerweile auch dass ich da
irgendwie kanal und nicht der beste drin
wenden was münzen angeht hier oben die
sachen mitnehmen hier bei euch darüber
sprechen über euch rüber
das war's mit super mario randi haben
angekündigt dass das ganze free sein
wird und was weiß ich und nichts mit in
app käufen unterschied hier kaufen diese
scheiß immer wieder ein paar schicken
den späteren kauf war erfolgreich
ja ich bin ein opfer
auch jetzt nur noch dass dinge ins spiel
nur noch dieses and level hier vorne in
welt 1 um irgendwie pietsch vielleicht
noch kurz zu befreien
dann hört ja auch direkt auf in dem
video also ich will nur welt einst wenn
ich mache mir den bock ablauf welt zwei
lassmann daumen hoch da schon mal dann
könnt ihr auch näher ich hab das ding
hin vergessen den ganzen schiff mit
nehmen euch hier vorne töten und die
mögen es nicht um korb ich krieg nie
alle münzen mit beim ersten mal was
nicht wohin sagen wollte wenn euch das
ganze hier gefällt dann lasst mal ein
like da und schreiben wir die kommentare
super-mario dran und wenn ihr übels
ausrasten da werde ich den zweiten teil
die tage davon machen wo wir dann welt
zwei durchspielen und dann quasi so
immer weiter und so fort also wenn ihr
da bock drauf hab hier lang durchlaufen
hier den dingens mitnehmen da unten
wieder stoppt gewesen und ich habe es
natürlich wieder verpackt drauf zu
drücken dann können wir hier hin was
dort genau hier handeln und jetzt da ich
ja am handeln könnten die amazon at sein
genau mir da eine münze geben hier unten
hier einmal um die kurse hoch springen
hier wieder handeln und jetzt runter die
münze woran ich habe das stoppschild
verpasst okay okay okay weil dadurch
durch ok da mal gut gemacht hause
du blöde kuh alter ich werde mal über
ihn drüber hat wieder super geklappt ich
habe den hammer
und er ist tot
und damit habe ich das double geschafft
das ging relativ schnell geht dir in
deinen ja wow ich dachte ich habe dich
gerade getötet man jetzt check der mit
piepser ab und mario muss wieder
hinterher springt der kleine italiener
aber naja ich würde sagen wir haben wir
haben das letzte level in welt einst
hingekriegt ich habe hier extra
belohnungen erhalten
die trotz level bekommen und jetzt
könnte ich quasi mit level 2
beziehungsweise welt zwei weitermachen
aber an dieser stelle beendet das
heutige wieder meine damen und herren
die schon mehrmals gesagt wenn es euch
gefallen hat lasten like da wenn ihr
davon mehr wollt schreibt eine super
mario rennrunden und in die kommentare
hier findet hier schnell die
eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf hier könnte
meinen kanal kostenlos abonnieren und
nehmen an einem gewinnspiel teil wo er
eine nintendo 3ds l gewinnt können
glaube ich so heißt der und hier findet
ihr irgendein anderes video eingeblendet
ist bestimmt auch komplett kacke
ja